نعم حقيقه تداعيات الزلزال باتت كبيره جدا
هنا على الاهالي في شمال غرب سوريا نحن
الان في حي القشا في مدينه حارم هذا الحي
الذي يعني يوصف بدمار ما هو الحقيقه اكثر
من 85 بناء سكني قد دمر بفعل الزلزال فوق
رؤوس ساكنيه اكثر من
325 ضحيه تم اخراجهم من بين الانقاض فرق
الدفاع المدني ما زالت تعمل حتى هذه
اللحظه منذ قليل بدات دراسه المنطقه من
جديد ولديها خيار الان
بنقل هذه الانقاض اكوام الاسمنت الى مكان
اخر لبدء مرحله جديده وهي انتشال الضحايا
الذين قضوا جراء الزلزال في اقبيه هذه
المساكن الحديث هنا من اهالي الحي عن اكثر
من 13 عائله في اقبيه هذه المنازل ما زالت
وربما باتوا ضحايا بحسب فرق الدفاع المدني
لا وجود لمؤشرات على الحياه بعد سته ايام
من حدوث الزلزال الامل يتضاءل ساعه بعد
ساعه وسط ظروف جويه قاسيه حقيقه حتى في
ساعات النهار هناك برد قارص عشرات
العائلات ايضا ما زالت في العراء
غير قادره على دخول منازلها المهدده
بالانهيار في اي لحظه مع استمرار الهزات
الارتداديه بشكل مستمر التي تصل الى شمال
ويتاثر بها شمال غرب سوريا عائلات ايضا ما
زالت تنتظر
خبرا من فرق الدفاع المدني عن الوصول الى
هذه الاقويه منذ قليل التقينا باحد
المسنين من عائله جنيد كانت فرق الدفاع
المدني قد استخرجت من عائلته ثمانيه عشر
فردا ما بين نساء واطفال وايضا مازال ان
تستخرج الفرق الدفاع المدني اثنين من
احفاده ما زالوا في احد
لهذه الابنيه حقيقه الدمار المهول في كل
من حارم وبثانيه وسلقين واضافه الى عده
مناطق وصولا الى جنديرس كبير جدا فرق
الدفاع المدني بحسب
مكتب الاداره اداره الكوارث
البحث عن الضحايا ربما يطول لايام وربما
لاكثر من شهر مع ضعف
يعني حقيقه المعدات الثقيله الذي هم بحاجه
اليها حتى هذه الساعه اضافه الى نقص
المساعدات الامميه فيما يتعلق بالوضع
الانساني هنا شمال غرب سوريا
الاف العائلات من غرب سوريا وحتى جنديرس
عفرين ما زالت تبيت في العراء وسط الظروف
جويه قاسيه وظروف انسانيه صعبه للغايه هم
بحاجه الى ماوى هم بحاجه الى مرافق خدميه
بحاجه الى عيادات متنقله بحاجه الى ادويه
وكوادر طبيه حتى هذه اللحظه دخل من معبر
باب الهوى الحدودي مع تركيا قرابه
20 شاحنه تقريبا تحمل مواد اغاثيه وخيام
وايضا دخل معه باب السلامه الحدودي قافله
اخرى من كردستان العراق الى نعم هذه
القافله العراق يعني نسمع كثير من الدول
تقول انها ارسلت مساعدات تقدر بكذا ومبالغ
ماليه جمعت
ماذا كان نصيب شمال سوريا من هذه
المساعدات من هي الدول بالتحديد التي وصلت
مساعدتها على ارض الواقع فعلا ان هذا
الكلام مازال مجرد حديث في الاعلام
عبد الصمد ربما تكون فيه في طريقها الى
الشمال السوري ولكن ما رصدناه خلال
تغطيتنا في معبر باب الهوى الحدودي لم
يدخل هذا الحجم الكبير من المساعدات نسمع
عن قوافل للملك سلمان او حمله الملك سلمان
التي ربما تبدا غدا وتدخل المواد الغاثيه
لها غدا نسمع ايضا عن قوافل لقطر الخيريه
وصلت ربما الى هاتاي وربما ستدخل الحدود
في الساعات القادمه ولكن حتى اللحظه ونحن
في اليوم السادس من الزلزال الذي ضرب
مناطق شمال الغرب سوريا لم تدخل الكميه
الكبيره من المساعدات ما تحدثنا به فقط
قرابه 20 شاحنه هذه
القوافل لا تسد الا جزء بسيط جدا من تم
الاحتياجات الكبير الذي
العائلات
بحاجتها حقيقه والكوادر الطبيه ايضا بحاجه
الى ادويه كما ذكرت بحاجه الى
كوادر طبيه بحاجه الى مستشفيات تخصصيه
للجراحه لان اعداد الاصابات نتحدث عن 5000
اصابه هم بحاجه الى رعايه طبيه لاسيما ان
الجانب التركي منذ اليوم الاول للزلزال قد
اغلق المعبر
باتجاه ولايه هاتاي كان سابقا يستقبل
الحالات الطارئه جراء القصف وجراءه ايضا
قصف الطائرات وقصف المدفعي الذي يتعرض له
السكان هنا في مناطق شمال غرب سوريا ولكن
منذ اليوم الاول تم اغلاق
وتوقف نقل هذه الحالات الى الجانب التركي
هذا ايضا زاد من زاد الوضع سوءا من
الناحيه الطبيه والانسانيه نتحدث عن حاجه
كبيره لالاف العائلات الذرات بفعل الزلزال
هنا في المنطقه عبد الصمد